[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the EA
play 2020 pre-show right here on
GameSpot I'm Lucy James joined by
Michael Higham hello everybody and some
of you saying
EA Sports supports we should be in for a
very interesting show today I'm very
excited there have been a lot of rumors
flying around about what EA could
possibly have to show a lot of people
hoping for Mass Effect apex a lot of
people cry now for dead space there will
always be a contingent crying out for
dead space but we're gonna go over what
we can expect to see from the show our
hopes our dreams Michael I'm gonna come
to you first
it's I can't not mention it the Mass
Effect remasters do we think now is the
time massive effects are about to happen
psyche I don't know actually but I I
would hope so
man you know I've been or all of us
actually me you and tam have always been
clamoring for Mass Effect remasters and
you know every time we get a chance to
mention Mass Effect we say hey bring
them back and I mean what better time to
do it then on the on the verge of a
console a new console generation right
maybe now's the time but we've always
been saying now it's time there's never
not a good time to bring back Mass
Effect you know I'm saying and honestly
I think that Mass Effect has been it's
been a long time since we've had that
original trilogy that there's almost
this wave of new gamers as you could say
that maybe didn't get to experience Mass
Effect back and when it was was fresh so
man it I think it's only a matter of
time until they do it let's hope it's
now also if they
if they could bring it to switch if
Bioware could bring it to switch you
know I'm saying that would that would be
dope but I've always thought of the mass
effect remastering the trilogy as like
break in case of emergency type thing I
know we were talking to
we had shinobi on the podcast not too
long ago and we specifically said that
like a you'll Bioware if you ever in
need of something just yell Mass Effect
trilogy remaster you know you know what
to do so that's how I feel I'm sure you
all do - yeah I mean we're all huge Mass
Effect fans right here and I would love
for nothing more than to replay the old
game because I always have the itch to
replay them but I've been holding off
just in case they do an answer remaster
but you know those are the older games
tomorrow what do you think the future of
Mass Effect is right now do we think you
know Andromeda maybe didn't hit as well
as they hope they would do they think do
we think you know it's time for another
so like I'm to borrow a phrase from
young Bernie Sanders I am once again
asking you for more Mass Effect like
it's I think I think the most likely
thing that we're gonna get Mass Effect
related is going to be if the remaster
rumors are true that because Bioware has
already said that their main focus is on
Dragon Age now and obviously that's a
studio that's also working on anthem on
the side we'll come to that later but
they do have committed to making that
game better
however they previously said you know
dead they are not done with Mass Effect
and you could take that to be like oh
we're gonna remaster but it when they
talked about it back in the day as a
couple years ago when they were kind of
like of rehiring a bunch of old leaders
from the studio that had left and Noah
be brought back they said we are very
much still on board with Mass Effect
we've got things cooking so I think it's
important for them to announce a new
Mass Effect but I don't think that's
going to happen yet I think what they
need to do and what they want to do now
is rebuild some of that trust after
Andromeda Andromeda not an awful game a
very very flawed game I think that the
damage that they did with that
is more sentiment and I think what
people need most right now is a reminder
of why they love Mass Effect's and
there's nothing better to remind you of
why you love Mass Effect and that
trilogy remastered looking better than
ever I started playing the first game on
PC again with mods and that kind of
stuff and it's amazing how well elements
of that game holds up the writing is
still very sharp and very charismatic
characters in there and very bold
writing in that game and I think that
just needs a little facelift and people
will forget Andromeda existed and be
raring to go for another Mass Effect I
think there eventually
my feeling is we will get a new Mass
Effect but I think we're more likely to
get a remaster before that and I hope we
get some look at that today I do wonder
if they do remaster Mass Effect you know
the pie in the sky would be that it's
all three games one disc or one download
and they kind of I don't know take that
gameplay and make it because this the
jump between one and two especially is
huge in terms of gameplay I would love
it if they just perhaps took the
gameplay from three which i think was
the strongest and unify it across all
three games Michael do we think that's
what do you think that's possible or you
think they'll keep it classic I think
that if if mass spec were to be
remastered I think that wouldn't have to
be the case cuz I still stand by saying
Mass Effect 1 is still the best one but
I do recognize that it is data y'all can
roast me okay but I think that if they
were to usher the entire trilogy into a
new era you would definitely have to
modernize a lot of the gameplay from 1to
still holds up three still definitely
holds up of course but yeah I would
expect that to come out of it but if
they were to do just like the the 4k HD
remasters here's the games again running
on new consoles running on new hardware
I would be fine with that but I think
that it because I have an attachment to
that but if they're trying to reach out
to a new audience which i think they
should because if you haven't played
Mass Effect like I said earlier
still fire but yeah that gameplay and
one could could definitely use of course
you would have to tweak it a little bit
because of the way that came encounters
are set up of course but man the mix of
like cover shooter plus the plus the
biotics and that the tech move set in
there oh my god man it's it's something
really special and yeah they would
definitely have I would think that they
would have to put in at work to make
that remaster work well and hey listen I
want I want more Mako sequences man
that's another thing y'all can roast me
on later is I love those scenes and down
constantly just firing it's a lifeblood
of the planet you know I'm saying what
if so I mean we mentioned anthem briefly
just that I assume we might get some
kind of update about what they're doing
with anthem
wouldn't it be wild if they just like
reskin the anthem as Mass Effect online
Mass Effect for multiplayer and then I
don't know cuz I mean I'm if they did we
don't know anything like if they did do
a remaster would they bring back the
multi play from three cuz you needed
that to get war assets so yeah what do
you think the features like fan anthem I
think that they've already committed to
making it better I think it's hard to
talk about what the future is with us
some sort of insight into like the
internal Bioware split on who's
developing what I don't Matt anthem it's
not dead but I do wonder how much
they're gonna put into it I think that
they'll get it to a state where it feels
better the fact that they've basically
gone dark on it is probably a better
sign than if they didn't and they were
still kind of like pumping out smaller
updates and being like cuz every time
they did that it was like people were
just straight-up tearing them apart and
being like this is this is weak so in
fact they've just kind of locked it off
and backed away and I like we're working
on this thing and I feel like Bioware as
a studio
the one thing they have going for them
is they're very upfront about the
mistakes that they've made and they're
very like they hold their hands up and
they're like we screw this one up we're
gonna step back and we're gonna try and
fix this the last time this happened we
got Final Fantasy 14 a realm reborn if
they can give us something like that
where they back away they really think
about what they're doing here
comeback and they give us a really like
well-done reworked version of anthem I
think there's the opportunity is there
for it to win people over and I think
people want to be won over something
about Bioware people want to love their
games and the kind of negative backlash
is usually because they've not been
given that opportunity to so I think the
future of anthem I won't say it's bright
but it has potential and I would hope
that they do bring back Mass Effect's
multiplayer mode if only because it's
match by 3 as Mark Kermode was like well
underrated and you do need it for like
the global readiness and order whatever
it's called galaxy radio that stuff but
it'd be interesting to see where the
anthem has any presence at this this
specific EA play event I kind of feel
like maybe not just because they've been
very quiet about it and it doesn't feel
like they have had enough time to do
anything substantial with it and when
they do show it off they want it to be a
big comprehensive like we're not going
to do this in phases this whole thing is
basically a new game now well let's move
on then to something that we do know
Bioware is working on and that is a
brand new Dragon Age so that was
revealed Game Awards two years ago I
believe with a little cheeky trailer um
Dragon Age Inquisition the DLC the
trespasser DLC ended on a cliffhanger
I'm not gonna spoil it here but it
definitely had a path that it was gonna
follow that was what 2014 it's been a
long time they have said that they're
working on it mark dara who is I believe
executive producer on the franchise he
is known for tweeting out getting
people's hopes up he's been tweeting in
ye olde english today and he said oh I
don't know why maybe it's just because
Michael Torre think it's in time it's
time
it's time to show something it might not
be gameplay it might not be release date
or probably definitely won't be release
date but maybe another teaser trailer
maybe a few more details or maybe a
casual update on the state of Jagan aged
four because like you said it's it's
been two years at this point since it
was kind of more or less confirmed that
it's being worked on so you know now
like I said now would be the time but in
terms of I don't I don't have my expects
expectation set high as to like be blown
away but by something but you know I
think this is a big deal man
and like you said by where has anthem
Mass Effect and Dragon Age and the one
that I think is the most on people's
minds that is still a lot of questions
is Dragon Age a lot of people are
waiting for that stuff man but you know
I hope they're if they were to do it I
hope they would be in a good state to do
it and not rushing things out because
that's the last thing I mean that's kind
of you know that's what happened with
anthem when you rush things out before
they're ready you got things like anthem
and Dragon Age a lot of people have an
attachment to it and it would be a shame
if it ended up in that case too so you
know I expect something not too much
just give us a little bit of serotonin
you know when it comes to when it comes
to Dragon Age serotonin did you really
just do that I'm so proud to know you
I know science all right well know also
because the character Sarah I thought
that's what the pond you were going for
yeah that - all right let's move on to
another studio who we know will have a
presence today we're gonna see something
from respawn they were tweeting you know
take a look at the future of Apex we all
play apex quite a lot we played with the
actual voice actors last week as part of
a play for all a lot of fun so we're in
the middle of a kind of relatively new
season I'm interested to know is it I
mean we just had logo launched is it too
soon to reveal
another legend Tam
I don't think so and to borrow a phrase
from young Bernie Sanders I'm once again
asking for a new local so like logo was
great I like her but I think it's weird
because she plays a lot like Sombra in
in overwatch and because of that I
haven't really stuck with her
mechanically she's not giving me
anything new to think about they she has
her own unique quirks but I really want
something someone different and someone
unique uniquely apex in the way someone
like you know Pathfinder was or
something like that or even race a
different kind of character and
different unique abilities to to kind of
get excited about I'd also really like
for them to kind of double down on on
story a bit more and we've had drip
feeds of it I think they really need to
lean a bit harder into it I think the
thirst from the fan bases is is is there
and they want to respond to lean into
that a bit more so I think this would be
a great opportunity for them to be like
hey also we have a new here's a story
trailer for something that's coming in
the future whether that's an event or a
new legend obviously I want a legend but
if it's just like a small event or
something like that I'll take that to
anything to kind of get us excited about
apex and keep the momentum going I think
that's really important like apex is
doing great right now but with you know
Call of Duty warzone doing so well I
think I feel like I need more people to
be swayed back into apex and I'd love
that I love playing wars on as well but
apex is probably still my battle royale
of choice so a fresh injection of
content and something to look forward to
will be great like we got Gio's I wonder
if you know expanding a squad to maybe
for people like in warzone and I'm only
just saying that because it's really
nice to play with three other people in
water and I would love that in apex to
Michael obviously respawn before they
did apex they were well known for
titanfall people are clamoring for it
they want it do you think the Stars will
align and we'll get it titanfall three
No Ida look she's official stance - yep
she said she said nope no titanfall
three for y'all but I mean I would I
would love it but I wouldn't expect it I
mean I feel like I feel like right now
they're are so focused laser focused on
apex that game is just pumping out or
respawn is pumping out so much content
on a consistent basis for that I mean
that's not to say that maybe they don't
have a team on the side who might be
working on a titanfall project but if
that's that's happening like right now
right now I don't think it would be
ready to kind of show off or confirm one
way or another but they really I don't
think I mean titanfall is not done
obviously there's they have something
very special with their I almost think
that like the some of the the
single-player stuff that they're doing
or like the story based stuff they're
doing in Apex they're kind of like maybe
flexing their their chops a little bit
in terms of like oh let's let's get back
to the story storytelling mode will kind
of warm up for what they got for
titanfall I don't know that's just a
thought but man there's so much
potential to take the titanfall universe
in so many more directions especially
with like solid single-player campaign
man I miss really good FPS campaigns and
titanfall to knock that out of the park
so they definitely have stuff to work
with there but no it's if it's time for
that I know that they have that metal
Medal of Honor I'll say metal gear for
the Medal of Honor VR game that they're
still working on so maybe we'll see that
first before we see anything on
titanfall 3 Tom what do you think
I think I want to borrow a page from a
friend of show Greg Aviles pay playbook
make the thing know the Greg Miller
playbook and make the thing that we want
happen by vocalizing it I think everyone
who wants it should go to an at respawn
with hashtags respawn and get the
campaign going four five four three and
leave a message alongside it and just
put in the message as young Bernie
Sanders says I
five four three all right let's move on
speaking of respawn personally I think
it's probably a little bit too soon for
any news on Jedi fall in order to you
know that game only came out last year
but it is a good segue to talk about
some Star Wars so obviously we're gonna
see some squadrons today we caught that
trailer on Monday Michael you're excited
yes because I think that the the aerial
combat and the battlefront games had
some potential it was it was pretty good
for what it was especially in a massive
battlefield style multiplayer game but
with squadrons really focusing on that
really honing it making a little bit
more in depth especially because they
they announced that there there's gonna
be taught us joystick support and all
that so that mean that gives me the
impression that they're really going on
in on refining the aerial combat and as
someone who played Rogue Squadron and
Rogue Squadron two back in the day on
n64 game cube that I have a lot of fond
memories of those games and if and I
miss playing like Star Fox things like
that so I and we already know kind of
the nature or not the nature but we got
that trailer and but there wasn't any
gameplay and you know it got us hyped up
to be like okay this is get some the the
true Star Wars vibes that we we love so
much but if there's gonna be more
details on squadrons I would be excited
for that but I would also expect a
little bit more information on exactly
how it's going to play whether it's
multiplayer focused with a little bit of
single-player content if there's gonna
be like a massive campaign behind it as
well
I think it's been announced as a forty
dollar game so III I would be hesitant
to say that oh it's like a a smaller
budget game or whatever
just because it's 40 dollars but it does
give me the impression that the scope
might not be that huge as like maybe
this is a massive follow up to the Rogue
Squadron games either way you know I'm
really interested in seeing what it what
ends up being and because man yeah
though those rogue squadron games were
five
and they can they got uh they got sort
of a foundation with battlefront aerial
combat so yeah give me more yeah and I
mean to be honest those x-wing type of
missions were my favorite in Alfred in
its multiplayer I know that for
battlefront 2 they've kind of said they
are finished with new content for that
game is now the time that they're gonna
roll into revealing anything about from
three do you think time I think it's too
too early for that like they've got our
front two into a really good spot and
it's being enjoyed they did I think I'm
right in thinking they as they said that
they were kind of pulling away from that
well I I believe that the kind of main
focus for the next you know cycle for
them is going to be battlefield so and I
don't imagine they're super keen on
having to Star Wars titles competing for
attention alongside each other
especially when one might involve kind
of pulling a fan base away from an
existing you know game so I felt like
they're okay with letting the
battlefront players play as they are and
then introducing something fresh and
different with the rogue squadron game
or squadron game and then going from
there and having them complement each
other while battlefield does its thing
on the side for the you know mains dice
game and there have been rumors that
vibe company 2 will get a remaster I
don't know if that's just wishful
thinking what do you think Michael I I
don't know II like EA has opened up to
remasters of course and obviously we
were clamoring earlier for a mass effect
remaster whether it's wishful wishful
thinking or not but like camp command &
Conquer just got remastered and it's
more or less like oh this is I've missed
command & Conquer and this is a good way
to enjoy those old games now when you're
talking about bad company bad company
was was really cool because it took
battlefield in such a different
direction with a single-player campaign
that was goofy but it was also a lot of
fun I would almost I would hope for bad
company 1 & 2 package remaster
single-player campaigns and maybe like a
unified multiplayer component for both
of them that would be dope that would be
also wishful thinking if they came out
with that I would
be excited for that and those battle
battle fronts whoa bad company games
work quite a while ago so there are
probably a lot like a lot of folks like
I said about Mass Effect there's
probably a lot of folks who haven't
experienced that especially because you
know you bite you can get them on back
and pad on Xbox one but uh shirring them
into a new generation I think is would
be like super helpful for EA and I don't
want to be the one of that that guy to
just like call all these remasters
remasters of course we want to see new
stuff but the thing about battlefield as
a series is that I feel a little
exhausted by it and I I've been playing
battlefield since 1942 not but not the
year
not since the 1542
oh man I'm looking nice you know Asian
don't raisin but you know I've been
playing their battle battlefield since
nineteen the since battlefield nights
forty to say that and I'm kind of
exhausted on the series I reviewed
battlefield five two years ago at this
point and I really really liked that
game a lot but I don't want another one
of those because I think battlefield 5
is perfectly far not perfectly fine but
could be improved but that is a solid
product right there and I mean if they
were to do like another modern one I
don't know I'm not really feeling that
so I think that if battlefield were to
have something new ish to show Bad
Company remasters would be pretty sweet
ya know I think Mike I think Michael
pretty much hit there now when they had
their Bad Company 2 is beloved and I'd
love to see a master of it alright let's
move on
PopCap so I love popcap games I think
peggle is one of the best games ever
made and I'm still really annoyed that
it doesn't work on iPhone anymore so I'm
gonna use this opportunity to say EA
what the hell paid for that app years
ago you can't just like leave it in the
past so that you can do your damned
microtransaction filled pop what is a
peggle blast which is rubbish it's gonna
say that
I would love to see peggle 3 I would
love to see peggle have a betta like
like there are so many ripoffs now on
the app store I would love to see just
pedicle return to the iPhone because it
is the perfect commute game not that
anyone has to commute anymore but I'm
just saying do we think peggle or maybe
even plants vs. zombies town III would
just want to stand by what you said
there and a hundred percent agree with
your your kind of assertion that we need
peggle we absolutely do need peggle and
I appreciate that you took the time and
used your platform for our for our
fellow peggle fans and in the spirit of
that I'm gonna do the same and poro
phrase from Jung Bernie Sanders doing a
kickflip alone in an empty parking lot
and say I'm once again asking for skate
for please give us K for speckle give us
K yeah Michael skate do you think it's
gonna happen oh no I just feel so bad I
just feel so bad for whoever has too
many A's to our account because every
time they tweet any announcement their
replies are just spammed with skate fall
skate fall skate fall
listen if you could if y'all gonna be
following this EA play that's coming up
soon expect the skateboard hashtags to
go wild man look thps1 and two times
poor skater 1 & 2 is getting a remaster
real soon
what's you know you can't just leave the
skater xl's coming out soon now that
looks pretty dope skate for man now is
the time to strike
come on man we've been asking for this
for so long it's been tent like what 10
years since skate 3 bro come on new
generation like I said bring it back cuz
a new generation wants skate out there
and I love skateboarding like that Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater influenced me
tremendously I talked about this at
length but man reinvigorate the skating
spirit with skate for please please
alright we got about 4 minutes until the
showcase we know that so Joseph Faris
who works on brother is a tale of two
sons and way out you might know him as
the swearing at the Academy Awards guy I
he tweeted that you should be looking
out for his next game at EA play I
wonder I
I'm very interested if it's gonna be
like another carb games how much think
yeah I think it's interesting because
like he he likes to try and mix it up
and do different things with his studio
so I expect that it will be something
different from you know another way out
or you know I brought another brothers
then again like the co-op element is
also what he's known for so maybe it
will be something stylistically and
subject matter very different but with
that seed of coop I think that's really
really what he's trying to make a mark
with his name you know around that style
of game so I I hope so I hope that we
see something that's a little more kind
of unexpected I'd love to see like a
sci-fi thing for them from him and his
studio now that has like a co-op element
to it definitely Michael what do you
expect from Joseph Forest most give him
yeah I think they you know they're gonna
let him go wild that would be that would
be what we want but man that dude was he
was a while into video game awards man I
respect it though you know I'm saying
like a lot of people might have their
takes about it you might not feel you
might feel some type of way about what
he did but I respect the energy
I respect the sentiment and I respect
his games I think you know like Tam said
he's willing to or him in his studio I
think it haze light is what it's called
they're willing to do something it's
something new and I you know a way out
had a lot of potential I think I don't
think it really nailed all everything
was trying to go for but it was like to
sit down with someone and figure that
game out even online I think that I
think the online co-op component to that
was it was really key and fir matically
like tam said I expect him to do
something completely different cuz
there's almost like no connection in
terms of tone and style between brothers
and
and a way out but yeah III would love
another co-op game especially in these
times man I want to play a cop game with
somebody so who Joseph where are you at
man damn yeah I'm really really I really
want a co-op game and in in kind of like
this spirit of trying to get a new co-op
game like to borrow a phrase from young
Bernie Sanders taking his mixtape to a
record label and begging for a deal I'm
once again Austin ei for a new Def Jam
game because wrong you are me wasting
that franchise give it to us
Bernie's got a mixtape put them in
SoundCloud rappers vs. oh geez I'll
write it for you if you want I also like
that ya hit me you can't use this
platform to ask for a job making the
next step Jam game man and if you but if
you do get it 8 put in good work I don't
worry I got you let's go look if I'm
gonna use it to ask for peggle back on
the app store
like that's 99p cuz that's how long and
God boy that's you know I'm just got a
few minutes apparently a start to 402 so
we got three or so minutes ok do we talk
about dead space do we dare do we think
it's gonna happen
Oh Tom what's that face I just really
need it I just really want a dead space
I want some of that limb dismemberment I
want some of that spooky stuff I want to
be able to point my hand at the ground
and have a little Waypoint take me to
where I'm gonna poop my pants next I was
about swearing I think like
survival-horror between between Resident
Evil the numerous amounts of like
messing with your mind survival horror
games that are out from Indies now is a
fantastic time for them to come back and
and do something interesting imagine
that kind of the weird zero-gravity
stuff that they did in the first and
second game just in an in the current
generation we desperately need a new
dead space I hope they give it to us I
really hope who would make it though cuz
visceral sadly is no longer Joseph
Farris Oh Michael
Wow look Victory's wrong and saying that
that dead space 3 was the best in the
series I love Tim turn a shout-out to
you he said what he said that's he said
the best in the series is not correct
fact you can hit him up but I love him
and he was right about co-op
I think co-op was probably my favorite
aspect of dead space to you because like
I'm it's uh it's not really that
survival horror that the original really
channeled so so strongly but you know
what get Dead's get Joseph Ferris on
dead space focus on straight-up co-op
let's go man that's that's my bold
prediction and soo man you love to see
it we have one minute until we go over
to EA so very quickly from the two of
you what is your dream announcement Tam
oh man
to borrow a phrase from young Bernie
Sanders wrapping up real warm trying to
do some skateboarding I'm once again
asking for an SSX tricky remake please
Michael I want
besides Mass Effect remastered I want
Madden 21 so you have I don't know a
battle royale I really don't
well we didn't FIFO have a kind of weird
battle royale games we know that FIFA's
gonna be there there's gonna be some mad
and stuff probably I know I am not that
audience but got a wrap-up we'll see
here after the show talk about all the
announcements please be Mass Effect
hello and welcome everyone to EA play
20/20 we're happy that you're joining us
today
over the next 45 minutes or so we've got
so much for you including creative
innovative and really fun new games and
a lot of news to share but before we get
into the show I'd like to take just a
minute here I want to extend a heartfelt
thank you to first responders medical
staff and essential personnel this has
certainly been a challenging year from
natural disasters like the bush fires in
my home country to the devastating
covered 19 pandemic these brave heroes
are working to keep us safe and healthy
at every turn I also want to thank our
teams for their amazing dedication while
working from home what you've been able
to achieve is nothing short of
inspirational we were also deeply
thankful to all of you our players even
when we've had to stay physically apart
billions of you are using games to come
together to play and do amazing things
for each other
you've shown why this is truly the
greatest form of entertainment on the
planet this is also a critical time for
the movement and racism and racial
injustice in this world black lives
matter and there is much to be done to
drive real and meaningful change a
couple of weeks ago we shared some
actions that Electronic Arts is taking
we will not rest on this it's a long
term commitment we're here for players
of every color background religion and
personal preference we will continue to
build strong representation in our games
and we are focused on making our
communities fun inclusive and positive
places to play we also have real work to
do to bring greater diversity into our
company and we are committed to doing
that work today we're here because of
the power of games games bring us
together they can make our lives better
they can teach us they can provide
escape
self-expression and most of all games
can be fun all of us Electronic Arts
believe in that and it's why we're
excited to get up every morning to make
great experiences for all of you so
thanks for being here with us and now
let's get into some games what's up
everybody I'm Greg Miller and welcome to
EA play we had an incredible show in LA
planned for you
huge stage massive set up these giant
monitors I was gonna fly in in an x-wing
I was gonna land the x-wing on stage I
was gonna set off a bunch of fireworks
then what t-shirt came and bam shooting
out game consoles then Carol baskets
some Tigers that last part was all me
then because of circumstances beyond our
control we had to come up with something
a little different instead of LA I'm in
my hometown of San Francisco but we
still have the Tigers let's head you
know Tigers so you like oh all right I'm
being told there are no Tigers but
whatever we're still gonna bring you the
EA play you know and love huge surprises
big announcements incredible reveals and
never-before-seen gameplay coming up
over the next hour we've got game
reveals galore world premiere trailers
of new titles some old favorites making
a comeback a look at a new way Star Wars
fans can live out their greatest
fantasies this year plus a sneak peek at
the future oh and pay close attention
because today you could win one of
thousands of steam codes for more than a
dozen great EA games on Steam throughout
the show keep an eye out for discreetly
placed golden letters write them down as
they appear and at the end of the show
we'll tell you where you can enter that
secret code for a chance to win free
games on Steam so don't go anywhere
Who am I kidding none of us can leave
our houses but enough talking let's see
some games up first we're headed to the
Outlands that's right it's apex legends
time
[Music]
you should smile
hey apex fans the battle just keeps
getting bigger thanks to you
apex legends is coming off its most
successful most epic season yet and
we're just getting started
season 4 saw more of you jumping into
the fight than ever before and you've
kept that amazing momentum going forward
making season 5 the biggest and best
start to a season ever hold on to your
Holograms we hope you've been enjoying
season 5 fortunes favor which has seen
the introduction of our latest legend
lova a major map change to Kings Canyon
rest in peace' skull town an all-new
ranked series and a ton of quality of
life updates but it's about to get even
better today I'm here to tell you about
what's coming next - season 5 with our
latest collection event lost treasures
take a look
[Applause]
adventurous Raiders explorers they risk
everything in such a fame fortune and
answers if you find what they're looking
for but if they survive they might walk
away with lost treasures
I'll high-five you all when I see you
mobile restored in here
register Thanks
guns who needs guns I don't need guns
I know what I'm looking for I won't walk
away without it
Dora teddy bear
it's me
as you just saw the lost treasures
collection event brings with it a ton of
great content including a new limited
time mode armed and dangerous' evolved
it's the return of a fan-favorite
snipers and sha DS only but with a twist
sending out my decoy all armor is evil
armor and we're removing all of the
respawn beacons across the entire map
don't worry though you'll still be able
to bring back your teammates with the
help of a new item the mobile respawn
vegan
you'll have one of these in your
inventory at the start of each match
giving you the power to choose win and
more importantly where you bring your
teammates back into the battle lost
treasures also introduces the new town
takeover kryptos map ring which gives
players a closer look at what motivates
this drone wielding hacker and of course
the lost treasures collection delivers a
bunch of exclusive content you can earn
by completing challenges as well as all
new event exclusive cosmetic items and
the introduction of yaboy mirages
heirloom which is fittingly a trophy of
himself excited to see you all on the
ring don't worry there's plenty of bees
to go around town and the best part is
you don't have to wait that long lost
treasures drops on Tuesday June 23rd and
that's not all apex fans the battle is
expanding that's right this fall we're
bringing apex legends to steam and I
know you're hoping wondering praying so
before you ask yeah
cross play is coming to apex this fall
it's been one of the biggest requests we
get and we're thrilled to finally
deliver it to our fans what am I
forgetting
oh yeah one last thing let's make it
official we're huge fans of Nintendo
here at respawn and we are incredibly
excited to be bringing apex legends to
the switch this fall and we'll share
more details in the months ahead so that
means you'll be able to squad up no
matter where are you and your friends
prefer to play xbox playstation switch
or on the PC via Origen and steam we're
throwing out a lifeline and healing the
divide between the platforms on behalf
of the entire apex team we want to thank
our incredible community your passion
for the game is truly inspiring we look
forward to seeing you all in the arena
and don't forget check out lost
treasures on June 23rd I think a cyber
but hyperbola I think I'm hiper been
is it a really good time here
Sol Sol everyone one thing I admire
about apex legends is its commitment to
having such a diverse range of
characters at the Sims we've always
believed representation and diversity in
games is critically important perhaps
now more than ever it's difficult to put
into words just how meaningful it can be
to see yourself reflected in the games
you play so here to tell you in their
own words are a few members of our Sims
community it's a very interesting thing
to explain it feels empowering actually
and very moving it really taught me a
lot the importance of just like keeping
relationships good with people it's
probably like the only place where I was
open they get to see my personality
first before seeing my disability I
guess you could say I found myself to be
the only black child in my school I was
discriminated I was bullied my skin tone
my height and my teeth first realized
that I was trans and I had I was like
praying to God to undo it I have this
world where I can express myself and be
myself where I come from Who I am the
color my skin you know who I'm attracted
to let any of that get in the way it was
it was no barriers no matter where I was
or what I was going through I had my
safe place this is plausible this is a
future you can have was almost like I
was peeking into the future and I didn't
know it at the time but it gave me hope
it gave me a sense of hope that I could
build a life that looked like that The
Sims is almost like a utopia of what I
hope our world eventually becomes a
cycle more comfortable with my character
in the
I got more comfortable with myself I
play to build neat I play to express
myself I play to make a difference a
play to feel good about myself I play to
have confidence to feel my creativity
it's more than just a game it's creating
your life
as you just saw there are so many
reasons why I am proud to be part of the
Sims global community we want the Sims
to be a place of unity and hope a place
where you can be your authentic self and
build your vision for our shared world a
place to imagine what's possible to our
simmers thank you for everything you've
done to make your communities virtual
and real a better place
now I know some of you tuned in hoping
for some Sims news and we'll have plenty
to share as the summer goes on but we do
have one announcement for you we'll be
welcoming players on a whole new
platform as the sims 4 arrives on Steam
today take a look
[Music]
and creatures
[Music]
we party coconut
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone Alex here from the social team
and joining me today from our community
team is Freeman hi folks yes we're here
to tell you that it's not just the Sims
for arriving on Steam today five more
great EA games including titanfall 2 a
way out and dead space free all playable
right this second
and when EA access arrives on Steam this
fall you can get all those great titles
and a ton more with your membership you
can also expect to see our new releases
on Steam - one of the first arrived just
a short while ago with full mod support
via Steamworks the critics love it and
we know you will too this is command &
Conquer remastered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back commander and steam isn't
the only platform getting some love
we'll be bringing games to more
platforms than ever you can expect seven
new games coming to switch in the next
12 months including burnout paradise
coming tomorrow and apex legends later
this year and we're bringing cross-play
to many of your favorite games -
starting with Need for Speed Heat and
continuing with some new titles being
revealed later in the show it's all
about giving you the freedom to play
what you want where you want and with
who you want it's about playing together
absolutely
now let's reveal some more games over to
you Greg quick reminder to keep an eye
out for those special golden letters
hidden throughout the show they could
appear anywhere and I mean anywhere so
keep your eyes open write the letters
down as they appear and once you've got
the full code you'll be able to enter
for a chance to win one of more than a
dozen great games on Steam so stay tuned
and find out where to enter the code at
the end of the show now if you follow my
content at all then you know there's
nothing I love more than buffalo wings
and discovering inventive new games well
I don't have any buffalo wings but I do
have something just as tasty over the
past couple of years
EA is partnered with the amazing Studios
like haze light and zone to give us such
creative titles as a way out in faith
here to explain how they do it are a few
of the talented developers working on
the next wave of EA originals
sometimes you just have this great idea
of a game but it can be really hard to
do it on your own we wanted space for
our Studios crates they would even flow
free so that we can find unconventional
approaches to solving new ideas there
are times where you've gotta like break
past your own sort of mental blocks even
if that meant building a whole new kind
of game engine we get to do the game we
want to do nothing and I mean nothing
comes into the game if it doesn't follow
the vision we can really push our ideas
further and bigger than we first
imagined
let's find that magic
[Music]
and now for a deeper dive into what
these developers are working on we turn
our spotlight on three Studios up first
is haze light in their mild-mannered
quiet leader Joseph Farris let's do it
please welcome Joseph Farah there are
like passionate people they're crazy
people there's me
[Music]
okay can you swear here his [ __ ]
Oscars you know not polish is there a
yeah I know I'm coffee I can't help it
man I was born in Beirut 1977
I lived there ten years it was civil war
and there was a lot of bad stuff
happening there we tried to move five
times to Sweden the fifth time they let
us in and that's like if you Sweden
because I've given Sweden a lot tonight
my third movies those are it's basically
about my life when I came to Sweden when
I was young I've done five fishing
movies and I have done three games and
it's very hard to make a game it's
almost like the audience have controlled
up the pacing on the story while the
movies is being pasted for you in video
games there's so much to be explored
from a storytelling perspective because
of the interactivity there are some
students out there that are making into
have good stories but they pretty much
have one mechanic like Yuri use all the
time the designers and the story writers
are kind of like doing two different
games that's why I founded his life to
keep pushing the boundaries of what is
possible in games
that's what game number three from his
life is all about
action the new game it takes to is a
co-op action-adventure platformer that
would blow your mind away the story
starts out with a small family Cody may
that's the parents and then grows the
little daughters so Colleen may about
separate grows doesn't want to be
divorced - she creates two dogs on a
wood and clay and these dogs magically
come alive and actually controls both
Cody and May and you could say you're
almost controlling their emotions you're
always playing in their emotions
there's even levels where we're actually
making a mechanic for their emotions so
again marrying the story and the
mechanics and I think for the players
that's gonna feel very new different and
unique they haven't played anything like
this before
it takes - is that crazy rollercoaster
ride that doesn't really have an Emmy it
has an ending but that end is that the
roller coaster crashes and you fly into
the sky and get up into space and when
you his praise you like what am i doing
up here and then maybe you get back to
earth again that's the best way to
describe that it takes to actually
Wow that was that was the best way to
describe it all right Joseph we love you
so much thank you keep it up over there
the Oscars of course ladies and
gentlemen let's keep this originals
train rolling and let's stay in Sweden
course I'm a fan of both their delicious
red gummy fish and their video games so
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Klaus and Olaf from joint games thanks
Greg
welcome to Gothenburg and will my home
unfortunately I didn't bring you any
Swedish fish but we do have some
exciting news for you about our latest
game at sewing we've always been driven
by love of rich visual storytelling and
creating strange worlds that people can
escape to the weirder the better and I
think my friend Olaf would agree yeah
absolutely and for our next game though
we wanted to try something a little
darker something out of a gothic fairy
tale but started with a mood and some
painting screw into this eerie strange
world that feels like something out of a
beautiful twisted dream and that's the
world of random lost and random is the
story of even a little girl with a big
heart and an even bigger temper after a
horrible event the changes of life she
embarks on a dangerous journey through
the world of random but fortunately
she's not alone just like I have Olaf
even also has a crazy little weird
friend thing with her along her journey
even discovers dicey a playful loyal
almost puppy like dice companion that
gives her the power to really change
things in the kingdom of random
despite the name in Eva's world
randomness is feared and a dark force
controls every aspect of life from where
you live to how you act or what your
favorite color is it's a coming-of-age
story set against the backdrop of a
mysterious world but it holds a modern
message that's really relevant to our
world right now I think we can all
relate to the desire to try and control
the chaos around us with Dicey's help
though even learns the power and doing
just the opposite
embrace the randomness accept
uncertainties in life and you'll be
surprised how far it takes you imagine
if you could change the course of life
with a roll of a dice what would you do
play it safe or trust in yourself and
take a chance we can't wait for you to
play and find out we're still a long
ways from launch but we hope you will
join even and dicey on the journey next
year until then please enjoy this first
look at last and random will come to
random the world of random bends with
the roll of one dice a die set is ruled
this kingdom for generations
transforming the fates of people just
tacky
but what if I told you there is another
dice with the power to change everything
now my friend it's your turn to roll to
play the odds and break the curse of
random
[Music]
you can't have the sweet without the
sour
[Music]
I know dicey they should be scared of us
right
[Music]
really cool that's a look at Lawson
random in man embracing randomness I
feel like I live that every day of my
life you know I was gonna do that you
didn't know that die seize my spirit
animal the games out next year but for
something that's blasting off a whole
lot sooner
take it away Kevin Franklin final strike
games our team of experienced industry
veterans have worked on incredible
multiplayer franchises we are
passionately focused on making great
multiplayer games that's why I am
incredibly excited to announce that we
have partnered with the talented team at
EA to release our first ever title
rocket arena as you'll see we stay loyal
to the name of the game
it's a rockets only shooter that allows
players to get into the action quickly
and stay in the fight we want a rocket
Iranian to be an awesome competitive
experience to play with friends I think
you're gonna love what we've got in
store for you here is the all-new
trailer of rocket arena enjoy rockets
away
[Music]
have you ever wondered why life is so
good on crater sure we've got the
beautiful beaches quality public
transportations and exotic destinations
the people are courteous and friendly
but the real reason life is so good
[Music]
let's get the trail
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm here to rocket
so as you just saw rockets are obviously
awesome to blast all over the place but
in order to come out on top there's a
lot to master you'll have a range of
rocket-powered abilities to blast
opponents out of the arena and an
arsenal of evasive moves rocket jump
rocket climb and dodge to avoid getting
knocked out yourself
don't worry though you're never out of
the action for long even when you're out
you'll fly right back into the fray
you'll also be able to really customize
your own unique look and play style each
of the 10 year is available at launch
have their own rocket-powered abilities
and as you play you'll discover items
that allow you to further refine each of
your heroes play styles Plus every
character has a hundred levels of
progression that unlock new cosmetics
and rewards all that and much more when
rocket arena arrives on July 14th and
there's plenty more content to come in
our first season which begins just two
weeks after launch on July 28th and
brings with it a blast pass and a ton of
free content including new maps in game
events and a new playable character
rocket arena is a game meant to be
played with friends regardless of
platform that's why we're thrilled to
announce cross play support right from
the start
so grab your friends regardless of their
platform and get ready to blast off with
rocket arena on July 14th on PlayStation
Xbox origin and steam and we'll be
sharing more gameplay right after the
show with the help of some great content
creators so check us out on youtube at
the link below see you in the arena wow
that looks great and hopefully you've
all been keeping track of the golden
letters hidden throughout the show and
nearly crack the code here's a hint it's
not Kanye keep an eye out for the last
couple of letters and then at the end of
the show we'll reveal where you need to
go to enter the code at a chance to win
some great games on Steam now from the
future of rocket warfare we head to a
different kind of battle it's the real
reason I didn't get any sleep last night
and if you thought you heard sleigh
bells that's because it might as well be
Christmas in June it's finally time to
talk Star Wars
squadrons okay I promise you we are
gonna get a first look at some brand new
gameplay in just a moment but first for
anyone who doesn't fully grasp why I'm
so excited
earlier this week EAM Lucasfilm dropped
a trailer that literally gave me all the
fields chills joy excitement and then
more chills on top of that take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that moment
I'm the perfect shot
makes history
five pilots one squadron the galaxy's
finest
[Music]
Wow the eight-year-old and all of us is
celebrating and excited the 37 year old
man on this couch is excited ladies and
gentlemen for the second year in a row I
have the honor and privilege of helping
introduce a new Star Wars title and here
to put the hype in hyperdrive is none
other than motives creative director Ian
Frazer hello Ian hey Greg how you doing
I'm great how are you doing good happy
to actually get to show this to people I
bet now in my copious notes I have on
you I'm told you are quite the Star Wars
fan and have been a long time how long
have you liked Star Wars
I've been a Star Wars fan for pretty
much my whole life I don't even remember
the first time I saw the movies and as a
kid there was a lot of different parts
of Star Wars I loved one of them was
being a pilot that idea of climbing into
an x-wing or a TIE fighter so you know I
played all the flight games in the 90s
and I got pretty obsessive about them
I'd pause meticulously draw the insides
of the cockpits and stuff and actually I
dug up some of those drawings for my
parents attic over the holidays we're
showing them right now to the world this
strikes me as above and beyond the
normal level of Star Wars fandom I think
it motive you find that quite a few
people have that level of Star Wars
fandom we started this project I talked
to a lot of people as they joined the
team and a lot of them had similar kinds
of stories of things they'd done as kids
one of them even built a functional
cockpit in his garage that's another
level how do you guys go from being a
fan drawing what you see in the game
we're building a cockpit in your garage
to actually making this game
well I think that fandom just love of
Star Wars has provided a really good
foundation for us but on top of that of
course the team at mode have got a lot
of experience working with Star Wars
when they worked on Battlefront 2 and
with Battlefront 2 wrapped up there was
a really small group of us that were
really into particularly the pilot
experiences in Star Wars and we wanted
to make something new something that
really went all-in on that part of the
fantasy and so we did kind of a
grassroots initiative our started a
little passion project and that ramped
up into eventually what is the game
we're going to show you today you talk
about you know your passion for this
your nostalgia for Star Wars flight
games of the past how do you honor that
but make something brand new it's been
interesting you know we're trying
kind of pull from that spiritual
heritage of many different games in that
time period at the same time we want to
do something that feels fresh and new
for fans today and so we've tried to
look at is sort of the spiritual core of
what I think are the best of the Star
Wars flight games of the past and what
they did that I love is that they made
that part of the universe real the level
of depth and detail that they show on
the ships the way that you control them
is something that I remember fondly from
my childhood and it's something that
we're trying to do very much with
squadrons you know in real life being a
pilot is hard it takes skill and that's
something that you'll see throughout the
game you know as you start off playing
it's pretty straightforward fly around
shoot your lasers but as you get deeper
into it you start learning how to divert
energy from your lasers to your to your
engines how the shifter shields from the
front to the back to cover your butt in
a dogfight or at the higher levels of
skill you could do really crazy stuff
like you can boost your engines fly
ahead cut them off whip around 180 and
shoot a missile off your own tail while
drifting backwards like real ace pilot
stuff and that's that's really where we
have a lot of fun with the game I want
to do that I want to learn too that I
understand the nuts and bolts of how to
play it is there a single-player story
is there a multiplayer mode what are we
getting into it's actually some of both
so the game starts with a brand new
single-player story takes place a little
bit after Return of the Jedi and it has
kind of a unique dual perspective
approach to it so when the game starts
you're gonna create two pilots you
create a new Republic pilot and an
imperial pilot and you're gonna
alternate between their perspectives
mission the mission over the course of
the story you're gonna meet a diverse
cast of characters along the way and
also a few familiar faces now when
you're done with that story and you've
played maybe a bit in the practice range
you say hey I want to try multiplayer we
want to make it really easy for you to
hop online with your friends and play
competitive space battles at that point
and so we've done a lot to try to reduce
the barriers to make it as easy as
possible for you to play with your
friends and so I'm happy to say we fully
support cross play you could be on ps4
Xbox one PC you could be playing on a
traditional display or in VR which fun
fact the entire game supports VR from
beginning to end
pretty cool but regardless of how you're
playing which platform they can all play
together just hook up with your friend
connect have an awesome space pad you
just discard my mind man like I don't
that's
awesome that is the big question when
can people actually play it ah not too
long actually start where squadrons is
coming out on October 2nd okay okay not
too long at all I was worried about you
I thought you'd leave me on a teaser
there you didn't actually deliver it I
appreciate that
the next big ask I have on behalf of
everybody watching I'm sure who came
here for one specific reason can we see
some new gameplay of it can we see any
gameplay of it absolutely I kind of
figured you might want to on behalf of
everyone at motive and the team at
Lucasfilm I am very happy to show you
the worlds first look at gameplay of
Star Wars squadrons enjoy
[Music]
second Death Star's gone but the
imperial fleet is still a threat and God
squadron let's make history
this is it Titan squadron everything
we've done has led to this finish those
bastards stop this is Star Wars squadron
earn your wings in a single-player story
spanning two factions all stations and
master multiplayer battles as a squadron
of five with the option to play the
entire game in VR this is the definitive
Star Wars pilot experience
[Music]
you'll begin your career in a
single-player story
welcome to titan squadron where you'll
play as two combat pilots flying for
both the Empire and the New Republic
you'll experience this world through
your cockpit the instrumentation in
front of you provides critical feedback
about power management targeting and
shields with a squadron of diverse
characters at your side prove your
skills on increasingly challenging
missions
welcome to the nadir Dockyard one of my
spies has leaked the attacks with the
New Republic star Hawk project the story
of the two pilots you playing stick
together will shape the balance of power
in the galaxy to take the fight online
you'll need flight time with all eight
ships fighters are the most flexible and
versatile able to handle any situation
interceptors are fast and highly
maneuverable let's get a ideal for
hunting down your opponent's star
fighters support ships can keep allies
safe and stocked up as well as
disrupting enemy fighters farmers are
the heavy hitters able to deal
devastating damage
enemy flag ships and star fighters if
you've got a preferred component you
need something customized I'll take care
of it unlock everything you need to
customize your pilot and star fighters
simply by playing the game from
cosmetics to an arsenal of over 50
components that alter how your ships fly
fight and survive deal with it you can
dramatically change your loadout
depending on your squadron strategy
finally got up this will be critical in
Star Wars squadrons multiplayer modes
first up dogfights this is an all-out
5v5 fine-tune your load outs to work as
a team moving in on the enemy utilize
compiled
but tractor beams turrets and mines to
slow down your opponent's or set up your
squad mates for the kill
four teams looking for an even greater
challenge it's time to prove yourself in
Star Wars squadrons signature mode fleet
balance fleet battles are multistage
conflicts whether playing solos or with
friends options against other players or
AI as a squadron of five don't worry I
got a point meet your team in the social
hub to solidify a strategy coordinate
loadouts
and prepare for takeoff first push the
front line by winning the dogfight in
the center of the map next attack or
defend to medium-sized capital ships
we've lost our capital ships and finally
the ultimate goal target and destroy the
subsystems of your opponent's massive
flagship and take you down at each phase
your squadron either pushes the line
forward or falls back to defend jeeva
flagship state is your squadrons choice
of how to play stay together strike
quickly stealth and subversion we need
to hurry
a unified squadron is the key to victory
cow
this is star wars squadrons join the
galaxy's finest
and make your margin
other hope this galaxy
[Music]
what's up everyone its super Lamar
Jackson I'm excited to be a part of the
edge for his family
it's me you guys new man cover athlete I
can't wait so he doesn't we have stuff
eating season
this is his fourth next up it's like I'm
late
I'm gonna touch the ball but not play
I'll fade that you see it's just me and
to keep it your heart is like
[Music]
scored a goal and your hero a history
call if your name you know what it
sounds like 60,000 people singing
awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
honey without our feeling tbonz for
football my heart feel it in comes
chasing see the unknown I want the real
thing I want not sweat with me since
little hair rosin
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to live on the floats
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to feel it's all a game now
that's a lot to look forward to but
there's more here to tell us about the
future of gaming is EA's chief studio
officer
Laura Miele thanks grey and thanks Lamar
welcome to the EA sports family there
are great things to come from EA Sports
for all of you and that's just the
beginning as you've seen throughout the
show today our electronic artists are
working hard to bring you more of the
games that you want to play games like
Star Wars squadrons apex legends and
command & Conquer these games all exist
because of you your voices are heard and
we are acting on your feedback now we've
talked a lot about all the exciting
games you'll be playing this year but
our studios are working even further out
creating new experiences new stories new
gameplay all enabled by new console
technology and we're so excited about
what's to come we don't want to wait
until next June to share what the teams
are working on
generation shifts are an opportunity to
push beyond the boundaries of gaming as
we know it today and this time is no
different our studios are taking their
crazy ambitious ideas and making them
real criterion is known for how their
games feel from superior physics to
nuanced details of gameplay this team
hand curates the moment-to-moment
experience and with the new consoles
this year there will be a seamless
immersion which will get you into the
race in a matter of seconds
Bioware imagines and creates worlds
where you've become the hero of your own
story and we're using this next
generation of technology to make those
fantasy worlds your reality for every
console generation dice sets the bar for
excellence in audio and visual
presentation we are creating epic
battles at a scale and fidelity unlike
anything you've experienced before
at motive we are working on a highly
ambitious and innovative new game that
puts the power and creativity in your
hands and it's an experience that would
have been impossible without next-gen
technology
[Music]
this is just the beginning of the things
we are working on and there is so much
more to come the future of EA Studios is
not just about new technology it's about
you your voices your ideas we want to be
where you come to play we want to make
games for everyone so please keep giving
us your feedback and let's build the
future together
on behalf of all of our studios thank
you for joining us today but before we
sign off there's just one more game
we would love to share cousin Darrin
over to you thank you so the moment is
here we finally get to say we're doing
it skates happening we're rolling we've
secretly got together
it's the beginning the skate evolution
continues we've been waiting years
honestly to to make the right game at
the right time with the right idea and
really really pleased to say that we're
here it is really early but it takes a
little while to find guys or wake them
up dude cars still we've got a long way
to go but we're stoked and this is just
the beginning and seriously we really
can't wait to bring you guys in and have
you be a part of it with us we want to
thank you for your passion your patience
and all the support that you've shown
you know us to get to this point in the
comments it's it's amazing we cannot
believe you commented this into
existence amazing skate changed my life
thank you so much escape forever guys
guys we did it we brought back skate
thank you to EA thank you to coz thank
you - Darren thank you you thank you to
me I can't believe that I'm so happy in
my heart rate is this what exercise
feels like ladies and gentlemen I can't
believe it before we go because I love
you guys here are the last letters of
the secret code if you think you've got
the complete code go to play or not GG /
EA and enter for a chance to win one of
thousands of free games sponsored by
player dot gg you can find the official
rules and everything else over at player
GG
ei now this has been in an amazing
experience an amazing opportunity for
all of us all over the world to come
together and celebrate gaming thank you
for being part of EA play until next
time I'll see you online and it's been
my pleasure to serve you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well no Mass Effect's I'm sad but you
know some very cool reveals that a brand
new skate cross play seemed to be the
word - sure
but let's go in-depth and talk about EA
play I'm Lucy joined by Michael hi I'm
whoa and tomorrow saying no I know I'm
so sorry we really wanted to see some
Mass Effect I think that was a little
hinted Dragon Age but let's go through
the press conference and talk about the
games that were shown off today so I
mean let's also talk a little bit about
annual sins comments at the beginning
I'm very glad that they addressed the
black lives matter movement as well as
you know their ongoing commitments
during the EA work force as well as
saying thank you to health care workers
I think it's very important for them to
do upfront and Michael what did you
think yeah I I think it's it's pretty
much a necessity for any company who's
gonna be you know front-facing during
this time is to say something I mean we
could have a conversation about like how
that turns out in action but you know
it's I think that there's the statement
at least across the board covered
covered those swath of things that are
happening in our world but you know of
course actions speak louder than words
so moving forward you know I wanna like
like any other company who's like saying
things like this I would take their word
for it but I also want to see how that
affects what they do forward and you
know at least from what we've seen in
the throughout this EA conferences like
you know we're starting to see a lot
more diversity as a standard across like
character representation and also like
people who make games so yeah I'm
excited to see what that has in store
for the future as well so that was the
love us from the start of the conference
and then the first game that we saw a
lot of was apex legends so June 23rd
we're gonna get a brand new limited time
mode I'm gonna throw it to you Michael
games I know you're big
mm-hmm so I actually got to talk to
yeah Grenier beforehand so I kept kept
my mouth shut during the pre-show but
now I think either now or a little bit
later you can see my interview with Chad
Grenier and at least after this
livestream don't go no right now but we
talked about the swath of things that
are coming to Apex legends and like I
said in the pre-show apex legends is
going ham and they don't stop
so season 5 was obviously big with Lobo
and stuff but introducing lost treasures
collection event channeling that that
energy from the previous was that the
armed and dangerous event which is
shotguns and snipers bring that back
tweaking a few things very exciting
that's coming next week limited time
mode and the respawn beacon stuff is
actually pretty interesting when you
actually get to play with it so that
that's gonna that's gonna be pretty fun
but as far as the big things go boy come
to switch I know I asked
Chad Grenier a little bit about if you
can get to the technical stuff but they
have nothing to say quite yet in terms
of like target resolution target FPS
performance UI elements that's all stuff
that we're gonna see it down the line
but I'm impressed that they're even
doing it at all just because of how huge
apex is and it's going to I think
something they didn't touch on in the
presser but I did get information from
him is that there's gonna be gyroscope
motion control aiming which i think is
really important because if you're gonna
play in handheld mode joy Khan's are
trashed for aiming so I think that's
very important especially because
they're gonna have cross play so if
you're on switch steam origin that's
another thing that's coming to steam
that's wild all budget yay games to come
to steam it's gonna be cross play well
we've been asking this for so long and
it's finally gonna happen
it's kind of an initiative across the
board with EA which is really cool with
a bunch of their games but put like
cross the board playing apex I love
playing on PC but I know watch my homies
play on ps4 I wanna play with them so
this is gonna be it's gonna be it's
gonna be dope I you know apex legends
keeps delivering and I'm excited to play
with more people down the line with
because I think cross plays coming in
fall and also the switch versions coming
and fall so those things will come out
right now exciting limited-time events
but man the future's bright for apex
yeah it is
you know the one thing I will say for
cross-play is that I hope they take the
precaution that if people are playing on
mouse and keyboard they're not paired up
against people who are on controller
like if you're playing on controller
through PC that's all well and good but
you can't deny that mouse and keyboard
is well I don't know because it's like
the toss-up right because you get the
auto aim coming through on controller
word so I assume they're gonna be
working on that term this is not an
apples to apples comparison by any means
but it's interesting that Michael
mentioned the gyroscope controls because
Tom when you play overwatch on switch
how did that work for you for a
first-person shooter I mean it was fine
it was it was not comfortable like the
the jitteriness that comes with
gyroscopic gaming is a big factor for me
and you don't have a lot of that on
console or mouse and keyboard but it's
very functional I feel like if you want
to play a quick game of Apex the switch
has enough options in terms of control
mechanisms to make that happen
I expect the like overwatch the
gyroscopic stuff might be a bit of a
curio that people try for a bit or it
could work out that it specifically
works really well for certain characters
like I found when I was playing with
gyroscopes aiming in overwatch that some
characters like soldier and that kind of
stuff wasn't great for it because I
wanted refined aim and control myself
but there were some characters that were
pretty good to do it with like Winston
jumping around and like quickly pivoting
your aim or even like Bastion and that
kind of stuff so it could be a case that
you know there's certain characters that
it works with and you know maybe a
pathfinder to brawl or something like
that but given the nature of Apex
relying way more heavily on shooting
than just your abilities
I expect that it's going to be a novelty
that people move away from and generally
will either use the the onboard joi cons
if they're wild or kind of thing like a
pro controller if they're if they want
to
so lost treasures goes live June 23rd
switch and cross player come in a fall
although I'm British so awesome all
right next up or the serious
next up the Sims kind steam I know they
just announced a new pack which released
a new pack very nice sentiment from the
sims they are very in tune with that
community that was a very heartwarming
and heartfelt just kind of celebration I
think of the community there I mean
personally I have the Sims through
origin so doesn't really mean much for
people who already own the Sims but
hopefully this opens it up a little bit
to people who just wanna play it on
Steam I don't really have much else to
say about the Sims I don't know
oh do we think the time is almost nigh
for Sims 5 Michael I don't know I think
I feel like with the the live service
style of games that we're seeing as a
not just a trend but just like across
the board games are adopting that live
service thing Sims 4 it seems like it's
in a really good place with expansions
and added content like I think it would
almost be a disservice that try to do a
Sims 5 because there's so many people
who are invested in Sims 4 and like EA
themselves I've done so much work to
make that game not just inclusive but
just giving everyone something to do in
the game too that that kind of strikes
their fancy as well so you know props
the sims for being that game where like
they said you know this isn't just the
game this is you know they get to live
out another life for themselves whether
they want to see themselves in the game
or if they want to be something else in
that game and just the wide swath of
things that mechanics and things to do
in that game that I've come with all
those different expansions so now props
the sims for that that kind of montage
and that's of like I mean they didn't
have a massive thing to show off that
was new but you know doesn't have to be
that and I appreciate that yeah and you
know they let on to the announcement
that a bunch of other things are gonna
come to steam so we already had Apex
Sims
title to way out Dead Space 3
not wanting to come on concrete mastered
and FIFA 21 Tam what do you think the
feature of origins gonna look like if
they kind of just moving everything back
to steam I think or it shouldn't really
impact origin in a major way I feel like
there's enough hooks within origin that
make make it valuable for people who
still want to use it whether that's
discounts or early access free games
that kind of stuff they won't be getting
any of that through Steam they just gain
access to the game I think it's only
beneficial for EA to make games like
these they opt right now picking
specific types of games that are moving
over and their games that have a
longevity to them or their games that
have been long soft like it makes sense
to put you know a cnc remastered sims 4
and an apex on there because they have
massive communities as is and by doing
so they only grow and time for two is a
beloved game so you know the who knows
it could be given like a shot in the arm
and multiplayer if they put it on that
and like way out for example is a it's a
great opportunity for people who may
have skipped it in on other platforms to
check it out especially given that hazel
has another game on the way and then you
know same for Dead Space 3 I think
unless I'm I'm forgetting like dead
space wanted to might already be on
Steam yeah so they think they were they
originally released on I have memories
of that because it's always in some sort
of discount deals promotion so I think
this is just completing the set to a
large degree but yeah FIFA as well like
it just makes sense to put them there I
don't think it has a negative impact on
on EA and origins on service I think it
only serves to help them and giving more
people access to their franchises and
games is only beneficial for you and I
think as well maybe it'll serve as a
funnel to get more people to subscribe
to the vaults EA access so maybe that'll
happen I'll see an uptick there you
mentioned a way out there so we also saw
a bunch of EA originals
um I always I was loved look I was look
forward to this section of VA press
conferences because it is nice to see a
juggernaut like EI take a chance really
on smaller and quirky and more unique
type games we've had sea of solitude
from them unraveled and so there's this
nice little cartoon featuring a bunch of
the developers that they're working with
they started off with Joseph Ferris we
know that he tweeted about it we were
talking about it in the pre-show so his
new game from Hays light is it takes two
they make a thing go right oh we both
went to Brady from the erections it
takes two to get two different songs
wait Michael what did you think
okay thanks - enough enough from y'all
let me boy let's see so spouses a tale
of two parents is very exciting for me I
think that that's gonna be a very fun
game to play as Joseph Farah says it's
gonna blow your effing mind so you know
I'll take his word for actually it's
called it takes two like Lucy said haha
I got jokes you know I'm saying but I
think that it's in line with him doing
co-op games so that part was kind of
expected now you know as it's funny
because Joseph Ferris is so full of
himself I love it I love how much he
loves himself it's almost like you love
to hate him or you hate to love him but
you know props to him for being being
that and really going all in on that and
I'm surprised ei replayed his video game
or its appearance so that that was nice
to see I guess but in terms of like it
takes - it almost channels a little bit
more of the brothers vibe to it because
it has a little bit more familial in
terms of its themes and for as frezz
into himself as he is I think that the
stories that are told in those games are
actually like pretty well grounded
obviously like Hays light as he said
Hays light is design as a way to bring
together the the writers and
storytellers with the people who make or
like the programmers so that they have a
cohesive game where the
anacs are also a part the narrative and
yeah that that's to say I'm also excited
for it and it's gonna tell oh man if you
got daddy issues or mommy issues like
I'm gonna be this might be a game for us
child of divorced parents a shout-out to
divorce you don't say but no that's not
sure divorce please all right whose
childhood trauma out here and that's the
theme of the game to at least from
what's being communicated is that you
play as a character whose two parents
are arguing they're like in the midst of
a split and you know the the main
character has like these two dolls that
are supposed to represent her parents
and then eventually it goes into this
more ethereal kind of surrealist 5 where
there's gonna be a lot of more co-op
gameplay mechanics so this is something
that I'm genuinely interested in because
not sure because Joseph Aras and like
the games that he makes but you know I
think this is something that can really
much channel that sort of energy Tim
what about lust and random from zoink
games yeah I mean that game it seems
really interesting I love the idea of
taking random elements of a game and
kind of making it the core conceit of
the actual experience so the game was
actually announced a little while back I
was like 2019 that they originally
announced it but I I'm interested in
seeing how it goes like you said earlier
these games that the EA shows are
usually the stuff that is really
experimenting with and doing like going
out there with so this is kind of like
mechanically speaking a really unique
kind of experience amongst this table of
EA games and it's just like referred to
as like a coming-of-age story and it's
got this interesting like Gothic
backdrop where it's kind of timber and
esque so like they talk about they
mentioned it being like a you take
control of a young girl who goes on this
dangerous journey through a world of
like random things and like you've got a
companion character called IC who's able
to kind of change change the outcome of
random events for you so i really
like the setup for it I'm really
interested to see how the mechanics come
together and how that randomization
manifests in gameplay mechanics and
ideas a lot of potential there I really
like what I'm seeing so far yeah
and then the final EA originals was from
final strike games rocket arena so I
think this one that kind of kid it
reminded me I think in style and tone of
the what was the game that was in the PS
5 and it was basically like rocket
League but oh c'mon yeah yeah I feel bad
but I remember with like the cartoony
kind of vibe that you get from it it
looks like a lot of fun I think there
was something like ten characters
dynamic maps rockets each character has
a hundred levels of progression I love
that kind of stuff I get really into it
I'm a little concerned that it's all
rockets though like I would like I mean
it's very much in keeping with the title
of the game but hmm I don't know I
thought it's gonna be enough variety for
me Michael oh one thing I will say about
it is that I think some we got some
information beforehand about it and the
one thing that I do appreciate out
appreciate about its approach is its non
violence so everyone has rockets and
stuff but the core conceit is that
you're supposed to knock them out of the
arena and you know I appreciate games
when they don't rely on violence as a
mechanism I mean that's not to say that
I don't play violent video games like
y'all I'm about to play less it was to
tonight so and obviously like apex
ledges like I play a bunch of
first-person shooters and all that but
you know when when a studio or developer
tries to go for that that's that that's
that's pretty cool so I mean maybe we'll
see how the mechanics shake out oh hi
sushi but anyway like a rock Audrina
like shout out to you all for trying out
I'm trying that approach appreciate that
yeah I mean very big splatoon vibes I
guess you could say from that to the
main meat I think of this press
conference I think we'll all agree Star
Wars
squadrons so there's a little interview
Ian Frazer that Ian Frazer
he came from the Mass Effect Andromeda
team and we moved over to motive we got
to see some gameplay a lot of really
really cool features here that they
revealed like you can play the whole
thing in VR there's a little room that
you can chat to you're like chat tactics
with with the teammates Tom let's talk a
little bit about it what caught your eye
I mean I think it's just the entire
thing was I think they said a lot of the
right things there in terms of what
people want the tactical nature of it
and the different play styles that they
highlighted like you can do a all-out
attack you can try and focus on stealth
runs you can do like just big bombing
runs I love the that kind of style of
play that you everyone's got a favorite
kind of ship everyone's got a favorite
moment from the Star Wars franchise
especially the dogfighting sections
where it's like oh yeah I remember you
know the stealth run in this movie or
whatever maybe so I imagine there's a
lot of wish fulfillment happening in
this kind of enabling different styles
of play and the tactical nature of it
seems like they very they are playing
they're up which is important like it's
easy to just focus on like the the kind
of surface level replication of you know
a dog fighting game install was
environment in space but the longevity
comes from how much you can do within
that the strategies you can employ the
missions that you go on and it looks
like they've have enough open-ended
stuff in here that it will be repeatable
and real replayable but on top of that
they've got that cool story which is
interesting I love the idea of two
pilots basically charting the course of
what happens in the world and you kind
of experiencing that through a
single-player story campaign yeah saying
all the right things looking the part
and showing off a lot of like depth
potential there I think it's a strong
start for this game so far yeah and
definitely Michael what do you think I
think that everyone got what they wanted
from Star Wars squad squadrons an
in-depth look at the gameplay and
like it's it's cool because my
expectations were kind of like okay just
adapt battlefront two's flight for like
a full-fledged game that's kind of what
I said in the pre-show but they went
into depth about how the team the
different kind of class mechanics work
in like in actual practice and that's a
very important thing to communicate when
trying to sell your game on this this
concept right and like having the
different different types of ships and
complaints or yeah the different
fighters like showing how they work was
was really cool and also the fact that
they're incorporating a single-player
experience along with it now it might be
something like four or five hour
experience sort of like what battlefront
two offered but the fact that it's part
of the the package is exciting that
seems to be some some pretty dope
characters we'll see how that how that
shakes out but in terms of characters
like there's there's some folks I want
to know more of I want to fight
alongside things like that but in terms
of the multiplayer there is like a
traditional kind of I guess I think
there was like a death death match style
mode but they're there they also kind of
walked you through a sort of objective
base mode where you have several steps
within a match that you need to destroy
this ship you need to protect this your
squad needs to move in this fashion to
achieve achieve this objective
that's all exciting and also shouts up
to like the UI designers for this thing
because it's not like a traditional
style where you have all the numbers on
the side of your screen all the UI
elements are on your ship and I think
that they've only shown gameplay from
the cockpit perspective so I think
they've said before when they first
revealed it that this is gonna be a
first-person flight game and I don't
know if that was just like an emphasis
yeah and they would have different
perspective options but it seems like
that that is primarily what you're gonna
be working with and the fact that all of
your UI elements everything that you
need to know is represented on the
cockpit of the ship is pretty cool and
the fact that everything's gonna be in
VR I don't know the VR is gonna be an
advantage or a like a disadvantage when
you're actually playing but the fact
that they're going to the lengths to
incorporate the entire game in VR is
also very
that's exciting too so I really feel
like they're they're going the extra
mile to really make this feel like a
full-fledged Star Wars experience damn
yeah I was just gonna yeah he's actually
updated their website to include a
little more content about what's going
to be included in the game specifically
the locations so if you're a match Star
Wars funny you'll see where you're going
you can check that out it's got lucky
evan prime sls and the theory dockyards
and see subo zaevion abyss and Gallatin
and there's like screenshots of each one
along with a little description and
there's there's like a lot of gameplay
overview stuff on the storm squadron
website so a lot of info they are very
much dumping out there right now which
is great news for people who are excited
about this so a little peek behind the
curtain of how we run the show as the
press conference is going on we write
what the games are and then we write our
little our names next to it about who's
interested in talking about like taking
point on that subject matter next up is
Madden apparently I'm taking the song
favorite how do you feel about who's
your favorite Madden I'd have to say mr.
Madden that's the way to talk about EA's
next-gen efforts yeah as you can see
right here next-gen world premiere we
got to see this trailer of I guess just
like EA Sports you know saying yep
next-gen is coming we're working on it
we're gonna see bits of FIFA here and
there bits of Madden and then in that
full next-gen cheat next in next-gen T's
you get to see some of the concepts that
they're working on from specific studios
like criterion Bioware and dice so let's
talk through all of the above
Michael what do you make of the Sports
announced Wii U you know did that pique
your interest or was it the other
next-gen T's that really got to you I
like sports
alright so we got two British folks on
here who only know football as the
footie sport where you kick a ball
around blitz you know as an American I
need
represent real football so Madden 21 you
know I'm actually a little disappointed
because I was expecting more details on
Madden 21 and it's it's cool to see like
Lamar Jax is taking a taking a tick-tock
on his own phone and putting up on the
EAS little play livestream that's cool
shot the Lamar Jackson oh my god does
one of the greatest seasons I've ever
watched or saw highlights of because I'm
on an NFL boycott but anyway Schatz
Lamar Jackson he's a cover athlete and
for me though I I wanted to get into
more depth of the Madden 21 mechanics
because they're doing it seems like
they're trying to do some more
interesting things with how that game is
played but overall I think that badly
see I needed to say something about
next-gen and it's pretty easy to like
package that with sports because you
know damn well like the sports games
going to come to next-gen things like
that but we're getting closer and closer
to these console releases I want a
little bit more details I know that
ongoing games such as apex you know I
asked respawn about what their plans are
they had nothing to share and there
wasn't really any like okay here's our
next gen game that we're going all-in
with was I want to see a little bit more
of that but you know not much not much
else to make out of it
I think yeah I was actually kind of
surprised given how much sports usually
take a lot of time up in ES press
conference obviously FIFA Madden they
are their bread and butter when it comes
to raking in those micro transactions
they make so much money every year it's
such a huge audience who buys you know
the new installment every year I was
very surprised that we didn't see more
they kind of slowly releasing details
about FIFA gonna come to steam but
nothing on this year's installments just
yet maybe what they I mean what they
usually do is like they kind of leave it
to maybe be closer to Gamescom time that
is still happening so maybe maybe that's
what they're just doing they're just
kind of putting it out there you know
and then we'll get to see all the next
gen stuff maybe later on in the summer
time what did you make of it yeah I
think that's pretty much what I FIFA and
Madden and
you know other sports hi oh they're so
big that I think they would need their
own breathing room and the level of
nuance and depth that you need to go to
really show why you know they need to
justify a new new version of a game each
time so whether that you know we've got
advanced new grass-blade physics like
they need to really get into the
granular detail to show the people who
love these games what's new like in our
crowd physics or crowd you know
rendering or all physics whatever it may
be and it's not great for those people
it's not great an experience for them to
just rush through it and I feel like
that would also eat up a lot of time and
then for everyone who's not there for
the sports they don't want 30 minutes or
how a ball is bouncing around the field
so I feel like the right call for them
is to kind of make sure that they're
teasing that stuff and then breaking it
out so it has this breathing room and
they can get you know various football
apollo's back to talk about at length
and get the developers to in to explain
at length why what's going on behind the
scenes to explain how next-gen works
with these four styles I mean like the
FIFA stuff is important the matter
stuff's important for like I think
there's still other things that need to
kind of like be touched upon as well as
part of this slate like the UFC I don't
know if that's still happening and NHL
and that kind of stuff so I imagine
there's going to be a drip feed of big
like me info drops on the sports titles
individually over the next few months
and like you said Gamescom is usually a
big one for FIFA so perhaps we'll see a
little more of that in a few weeks we
also got that next-gen tees so it's very
specific Studios that were mentioned you
know criterion um are they what are they
working on the brand-new Need for Speed
yes so Need for Speed is the next game
from criterion they officially said that
they're ending support for the current
need for speed so they can you know
shift over to that stuff that was in the
news a couple weeks back it makes a lot
of sense the studio's been kind of like
helping out on racing trails and also
supporting Star Wars titles but they are
now custodians of Need for Speed
wholesale I believe and so that's
exciting
they make great games they make great
racing games hopefully they can get Need
for Speed back on some sort of
I call Road I don't know how that works
I was excited I wonder what's gonna
become a ghost games then you didn't
need to speed a few years ago who knows
Jen ghosted Bioware got mentions this is
the only mention of Bioware in this
whole press conference
Geoff Grubb has been tweeting a lot
about you know leaks and stuff over the
summer he's mentioned he's kind of done
like an update tweet he said battlefield
6 is gonna be modern UFC is coming he is
gonna make a golf game on its own again
Battlefield Bad Company remastered Gork
and Mass Effect 3 mass is coming this
year Bioware already said it's working
on anthem 2.0 and Dragon Age 4 so that's
the update from I'm not gonna say that
his insider knowledge if it is insider
knowledge is correct but this is what is
going around on lying right now that T's
that we got there from Bioware
definitely look like Dragon Age to me
they mentioned building your fantasy
worlds I assume that's definitely Dragon
Age we know they're working on it yeah
oh Michael what do you think about what
you know man it's I think it's fair to
say that Bioware fans are we can say
we're disappointed right but that
doesn't like that we don't mean any
ill-will when we say that it's just like
okay we're like we're ready to see what
y'all got maybe they're not ready that's
fine but I said in the pre-show that
like they don't have to show Dragon Age
for gameplay but maybe an update on the
state of the game some ideas that they
have going maybe like a short little
teaser trailer who didn't even really
get that so you know I don't want to
complain but it was a little
disappointing to get no Dragon Age 4
news because this is in lieu of III also
so yeah those little disappointing but a
play like we keep saying that the Mass
Effect remasters where it where that I
mean yeah sorry caramel okay
are you done like yes yielded I was so
sorry I thought you still had like one
more thing I just want to make sure
forgets the time time you can talk to
about bio a - but what else did you make
of that that's showing from DICE it was
kind of strange it was like a third
person tumbling through the air you had
no no you're not gonna over blocks what
was that about yeah I mean firstly the
lack of bio way is upsetting to me and I
feel personally slighted because I'm a
gamer online so that's how I behave but
the other kind of like weird new kind of
tech thing that they were showing like
it's super early I'm not sure what that
was even so like it's really hard to get
an indication of what that game could be
it reminded me of remember that ps3
launch title pain where you just like
flung a dude things and allowed it
allowed like bad things to happen to him
but it looks like this is just them
saying like hey we're working on an
engine we've got something exciting that
dude falling through the air short it
looked like a bounty hunter but you know
who knows that could be a Star Wars
thing it could be something else
entirely but like the jetpack vibe that
he had I was like maybe maybe like an
open-world bounty hunter game who knows
but yeah it's too early to say what it
could be but it's just in saying hey
we're working on next gen technology so
please be excited not much together from
it but good luck to them basically
alright and let's end on the surprise
reveal the just one more thing a new
skate game hey your plea whoa I told you
Bernie Sanders alone in a skate park
doing an ollie on his own
finally is happy we once again asked for
skating for and we got day before we got
we got skate they didn't say skate for
they said skate is back which is
interesting so if it turns out to be a
remaster sure why not we'll take
anything at this point but I do wonder
whether it's a full sequel or if it is a
remaster because if it's a remaster
that's probably a way to hedge your bets
lightly
he has traditionally not shown a lot of
faith in the skating genre especially
for video games by imagine they're like
peeking through the window of steam and
seeing like skater Excel and everything
else kind of like coming out and being
like everyone's making skate games we've
got this one game that people will not
stop spamming hashtags about maybe we
can remake one of the previous games in
the franchise or if they are bold enough
to put a whole new skate game in there I
respect it I think the important thing
is like from the fanbases perspective
they're happy either way like we've got
something to do escape Michael your big
skate fan
help us make you feel sure it made me
feel a lot of things alright I
but now the TAM has mentioned it you
know they didn't explicitly say skate
for but that's what everyone's thinking
I you know to be to be honest though
like I don't think remastering the skate
games would be I don't think that that's
the route that most people want because
like if you think about it like even
though skate three a hat it's been ten
years since skate 3 but if you go back
and replay that game it holds up really
well I don't really think that game
needs a remaster it just it it already
feels really good or it feels good still
to play but uh shirring in skate the
series into a next generation because
like they didn't say anything definitive
so it's probably always out 2021
probably but you know if they're gonna
if that's what they're gonna end on and
you know make a statement about the
thing that people have been clamoring
for for multiple years it would have to
be a full-on sequel or next-gen game for
skate but you know there we didn't get
any gameplay we didn't get any like its
user trailer they just kind of said all
skates back which is you know what
that's that's enough for me that that
gives us hope and it gives me hope to
see that like that they understand what
the like fans or that fans wants so
whenever we do get to see gameplay or a
trailer or more details on it I do have
faith that it will be the thing that
everyone wants whether it's skate 4 or
scape rename with whatever subtitle but
yeah I'm ready
you know thps1 and to remaster comments
gator excels out there or it's coming
out there
ready for a real-deal kickflips bro
let's go
all right over Altima what did you think
of VA play 2020 no Mass Effect no Dragon
Age one out of ten Wow damn
cutting Michael spicy um it was it
wasn't that hype you know it wasn't like
terribly exciting but you know I'm
excited for the things they showed I'm
excited that we got to see Greg Miller
out there a fresh haircut you know I'm
saying sure though sure
yeah homeboys looking real nice so show
us up to him Lucy tell him that I'm a
big fan of his haircut I was nice but
you know good son there are some things
that are better dope I think them going
all-in with Star Wars squadrons was was
a good call mentioning skate for was a
good call
of course like like Tam said they know
Mass Effect no Dragon Age so I'm nice
obviously two out of ten
no I'm just kidding good but it was it
was it was decent I'm feeling it yeah
yeah
I mean I think the curse that ei is
always gonna have now is you know
they've given in they've relinquished
and done escape whatever the new escape
is I'm just gonna say skate for for the
purposes of this analogy but you know
now every time they're gonna do
something it's gonna be where's Mass
Effect where's Dragon Age and it's a
blessing and a curse because you've got
a very passionate fan base but it kind
of means that everything else is drowned
out by those voices a little bit I'm of
the opinion like that conference was
kind of a nice all-rounder it didn't
have as many like big huge announcements
as I would have liked but getting to see
more of Star Wars getting my apex news I
love the way they're continuing to
support that front well franchise so to
speak it's within the titanfall world
the way they're supporting that game and
giving it light to shine because if you
think about the way it was announced it
was very much BAM we've done this we
have you know it's out now so I'm loving
the it spot like I'm gonna be one of
those people who wants the most effect
but I can wait for it
No all right oh it looks great yeah that
was looks great yeah a Star Wars hashtag
skate skate for squeeze squeeze
oh let's go Star Wars Gators
let's go Darth Maul was in Tony Hawk's
Pro Skater come on let's go look the
crossovers happened let's make it happen
again Michael oh Tom thank you so much
for joining me today and thank you
everyone who's been in the chat watching
along with us GameSpot has all the huge
announcements from this summer as part
of our play for all which is a mix of
well the big kind of announcements all
the big gaming stuff that you would
expect from e3 as well as daily charity
stream for raising money for black lives
matter as well as Direct Relief and that
kovat 19 relief efforts so please donate
come join us on a stream one of these
days got some great guests lined up
we've got last podcast on the left
tomorrow we've got Joe seizure from Fire
Emblem three houses a lot of other fun
stuff planned thanks again for joining
us we'll see you next time peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]